yeah all right so like that I know the
question that's top of mind what's in
the latest issue of Reason magazine
let's talk to reason editor-in-chief
Matt Welch can I handle the truth we
have a cover story written by yours
truly about how the truth hurts there's
been a long kind of bubbling meme out
there among political journalists that
they need to do a better job of calling
out politicians especially who are lying
we're prevaricate and so we've seen this
proliferation of fact checks and all
these other things what I'm talking
about in this piece is how this kind of
newly energized press that claims to be
out there truth-telling and
fact-checking is using it in very
partisan means in the meantime not using
that sentiment and not using that energy
against the people who actually hold
power Barack Obama at this point it
sounds like a well-crafted distraction
now when we talk about truth there's a
very subjective element in sex work sex
workers and how they see themselves
versus anti-sex trafficking activists
yeah so Melissa take your grants wrote a
piece about the war on sex workers
basically where people have channeled
their traditional anti-prostitution
feeling in this more feel-good anti-sex
trafficking thing where if you believe
these activists they are going after the
12 year old sex slave from bangladesh
but they can plate all sex work
invariably with that so they go after
places like Craigslist backpage.com
places that advertise sex work for
people who are doing it as adults will
willingly between one another and now on
to New York City which should be the
capital of fun but whether you're
talking about handguns or tattoos the
modern-day New York had its roots in
some old school jazz in the 40s and 50s
where musicians were penalized great
great piece by Chris cornice talking
about this prohibition era element of
Cabaret cards you need a license as a
performer to perform in a new your
club any kind of club basically so
people like Charlie Parker he wasn't
allowed to perform at Birdland in Harlem
of all places club named after him Lenny
Bruce was ultimately denied his cabaret
license because of an obscenity charge
that he had elsewhere and it just shows
how out of touch New York politicians
have been for so many decades something
cool and is American as jazz and now it
sort of bleeds into the modern age and
you don't have to take too much of a
metaphor to see that Mayor Bloomberg is
notorious as nanny I mean a reason we
call nanny a month just about every
month all right truth sex and jazz
naughty never read so nice go pick up a
reason today for recent TV I'm Kennedy
you